foreign
[Music]
with Spider-Man Venom and morbius three
major characters have already been
introduced in Sony's Spider-Man universe
with varying levels of success among
fans of course the universe will
continue to expand in 2023 besides the
animated film Spider-Man across the
spider-verse around Miles Morales the
next live-action film with a new main
character Oasis in October the talk is
of Craven the hunter with Craven the
last of an Infamous group of villains
makes it into the spider-verse bringing
with it lots of speculation do you want
to know what it's all about and don't
want to search through hundreds of
articles about the new Sony Blockbuster
well perfect because in this video we
have compiled all available information
and facts about Craven the hunter just
for you
let's talk about the aforementioned
group of villains Craven's addition to
the SSU means that the establishment of
the so-called Sinister Six is becoming
even more likely the members Venom and
morbius have been introduced with their
own movies already and Michael Keaton's
vulture is already known to us as well
he was in prison with none other than
scorpion in Spider-Man homecoming so
with Craven we already have five out of
the six villains assembled whether there
will be an overlap with morbius Venom or
Spidey in his solo film already is not
yet known their actors are not mentioned
in the previously announced cast however
a brief appearance of at least
Spider-Man seems likely since he is very
closely associated with Craven in the
comic original should the sixth villain
of the Sinister Six not yet play a major
role in Craven the hunter we fully
expect him to be teased at the end of
the movie at the latest possible here
are all kinds of antagonists from
Spider-Man's film and comic book history
we already know quite a bit about the
cast of Craven the hunter however it's
unclear who exactly will be the
antagonist and who will stand by crave
inside it's hard to tell since we'll
mainly be dealing with rather evil
characters in order for you to get an
idea of the possible alliances yourself
we would like to present the cast and
their characters in the comics in more
detail this also includes storylines
that might also be adapted into film in
one way or another so if you want to
avoid any potential spoilers you should
rather skip this part of the original
episode
of course Sergey cravenov AKA Craven the
hunter leads off the cast he's played by
Aaron Taylor-Johnson for the Kick-Ass
and Godzilla star this is already the
second role played in a Marvel film
quite a few of you will know him as
Wanda's brother Quicksilver from
Avengers Age of Ultron Sergey comes from
a noble family that had to flee Russia
to the United States once there Sergey
is no longer part of the upper class but
a common citizen he strives to become
something extraordinary again and begins
big game hunting during one of his
travels he meets the voodoo priestess
Calypso she mixes a mystical serum for
him which is supposed to give him the
strength and speed of a lion thus Sergey
cravenov becomes Craven the hunter back
in the USA he first uses his new powers
for good and even fights the Red Skull
along with Nick Fury it is only through
his half-brother Dimitri that he becomes
aware of Spider-Man he has some issues
with the friendly neighborhood spider
and asks Craven to support him in the
fight as a big game hunter Craven's
ambition is naturally awakened to hunt
down what is probably the biggest spider
in the world
Dimitri smyrdyakov the aforementioned
half-brother is already confirmed for
the film Fred Hettinger will play the
role of the so-called chameleon he was
last seen in the Netflix crime filler
the pale blue eye as the name of his
alter ego suggests chameleon can
disguise himself as any human being and
mimic them perfectly Dimitri and Sergey
have the same father however since
Dimitri's mother was a simple servant
everyone in the family hated him since
Sergey was subjected to his father's
frustration he in turn vented his own on
Dimitri nevertheless the latter always
imitated his big brother and tried to
impress him once he goes to America his
skill turned out to be extremely useful
for example he attempts to steal rocket
codes while disguising himself as
Spider-Man marking the beginning of his
Feud with Peter Parker since Dimitri has
no other superpowers worth noting he
eventually turns to his brother for help
of course the movie also features the
voodoo priestess who uses her mystical
serum to give Craven the powers that
turn him into a superhero or villain she
is played by Ariana Dubose the young
actress made her breakthrough in
Hollywood a while back and even when the
Oscar for best supporting actress in
Steven Spielberg's West Side Story in
2022 Calypso not only turned Sergey into
Craven but likewise keeps inciting him
to fight Spider-Man in the comics she
has already met Spidey several times
she'd Bewitched Daredevil and the lizard
and sicked both of them on Peter Parker
to what extent she will join Craven in a
Solo film remains to be seen of course
however since the role is cast by such a
top class actress we do expect we'll get
to see her quite often
another villain will be the Foreigner he
will be played by Christopher Abbott who
has been featured in the drama first man
and the series Catch-22 for example who
exactly the Foreigner is is also not
clear from the comics the Spider-Man
antagonist is a feared mercenary and
assassin he can also hypnotize people
for a short time which makes him
dangerous for superheroes as well of
course he is also in touch with sergey's
brother Dimitri on a regular basis
privately we only know that he's been
involved with the one or other woman
from Spider-Man's life though they have
not played any part in the previous
films more interesting he is good
friends with Kingpin who last appeared
in Hawkeye the gangster boss might also
be integrated into the spider-verse in
this way
three actors are on the cast list of
Craven the hunter for which we don't
have a confirmed role yet in first
position is Russell Crowe he only had a
superhero appearance as Zeus the father
of the Gods in Thor love and thunder in
2022. it is imaginable that he will take
on the role of Craven's father Nikolai
cravenov in order to better illuminate
the family's backstory the young Levi
Miller will also be playing a part he
made his breakthrough as Peter Pan in
the 2015 film pan so far there are no
clues as to who he will play possible
are young versions of Sergey or Dimitri
last but not least we have Alessandro
navolo he stated in some interviews that
he will play the main antagonist of
Craven however who exactly that will be
Still Remains a mystery but the
character is supposed to be a classic
Spider-Man villain whose psyche and
personality will be the main focus this
is reportedly also what prompted devolo
to accept the role we can't wait to find
out who the filmmakers will present as
the big adversary
there is plenty of room for speculation
as to how all the story lines from the
comics will ultimately be realized in
the film without a trailer or official
details about the plot there are only a
few Clues however a few key points are
considered very likely since the
character has not appeared in other
movies so far it will surely be an
origin story We believe that sergey's
backstory will play an important role
we'll probably be following the young
Craven from Russia to America and
experience the frustration of a family
that was at the very top and ended up at
Rock Bottom this theory is backed up by
Alessandro navolo he confirmed in an
interview that there will be a big time
Jump within the movie there will be
complex character developments so we'll
get to meet different Cravens two
brothers who want to prove it to
everyone and a main character who after
meeting Calypso has to look out for what
he should use his new powers for sounds
like the fitting Spider-Man saying with
great power comes great responsibility
doesn't it we can expect Craven much
like Venom and morbius to emerge as an
anti-hero rather than a typical villain
it's entirely possible that he will
initially act selfishly due to his
family history would end up undergoing a
transformation albeit not into a shining
Spidey type superhero we're curious to
see whether Craven and Calypso's
romantic entanglements from the comics
will also play a role in the movie at
least a touch of magical seduction would
certainly suit the voodoo priestess big
questions were made about Spider-Man's
role despite his great importance in the
comics it is improbable that he will
show up a lot if at all in the first
Craven film no matter what you read
about the project you won't find Peter
Parker's name anywhere what is
conceivable is that Dimitri will have
problems with the Foreigner and Craven
will have to bail him out via the
Foreigner and the main antagonist one
can find the turning point to Spider-Man
at the end perhaps as a post-credit
scene
the director's chair for craving the
hunter is reserved for JC chandor this
is the director and screenwriter's first
time working on a superhero movie most
recently he was in charge of the 2019
Netflix film triple Frontier where he
was able to direct Stars such as Ben
Affleck Oscar Isaac Charlie Hunnam and
Pedro Pascal the screenplay was written
by Richard wank art Markham and Matt
Holloway the role of Craven was
originally offered to Keanu Reeves who
declined with thanks however shooting
for the film started in London in
February 2022 and was already concluded
in mid-june 2022 one special feature of
the film is to do without an excess of
CGI FX instead the physical abilities of
the characters are to be portrayed as
realistically as possible Craven the
hunter is scheduled to be released in
movie theaters on October 6 2023 we
therefore hope to see a first trailer
for the film anytime soon
this was our preview of Craven the
hunter what do you all think will Sony
manage to turn things around after
morbius and bring another successful
Marvel movie to the big screen with
Craven the hunter let us know in the
comments if you like this video feel
free to give it a thumbs up thanks for
watching
[Music]